hey guys you've been asking for me to
make more content so let's do it every
wednesday 8pm we're going to have a new
episode for you
where i'm going to tackle the newest
headlines the craziest articles
maybe touch on some research and give
you some updates on what i'm up to to
kick off this wednesday show
i decided to watch a medical drama that
just came out last night
you've been asking for it and you got it
new amsterdam let's go
dr bloom she's dead no pulse no bp
cyanotic rigor mortis
i need a d5 ventilator als and
resuscitation team
now that's impossible she's dead well at
least she didn't kill her twice
if she wasn't dead you need to start
doing chest compressions if you're
getting a defibrillator
so i'm not sure what happened in that
scene going somewhere
i have to type segments with the morning
show and megan kelly then give the
keynote address at the oncology
conference in vail i'll take that for
you thanks i've done a couple segments
on megyn kelly
you're funny i'll be back next week your
lunch at the tavern
my treat unlike the previous medical
director i actually expect you to
practice medicine
at this hospital because i don't know
it's your job you're funny
you said that i'll tell you what i'll
continue giving speeches all over the
world because you can't afford
the kind of publicity i give this
hospital i understand what they're
trying to set up
uh one doctor actually wants to practice
medicine the other doctor is trying to
be more
media savvy this is something i have to
reevaluate sometimes like how much time
am i spending
practicing medicine versus doing media
and social media i think it is important
to do media as long as you're doing it
the right way
because you can deliver a very
meaningful health message
to millions of people instead of the 30
40 that you may see in your office
plus you can get notoriety and funding
for your hospital
for a non-profit for disease research
i think those are very useful
uh uses of social media and media in
general that sometimes go overlooked
while i don't necessarily agree with how
she presents herself
i kind of understand her message and
where she's coming from will everyone in
the cardiac surgical department please
raise your hands don't be shy just get
them up there
great
great thank you you're all fired
any department who places billing above
care
no matter how much money you make this
hospital you will be terminated oh i am
serious
whoa i doubt that that's what happens
just because number one people have
contracts
and number two you're going to be
hurting a lot of people who need cardiac
care that won't be able to get it from
your hospital because you just fired
everybody so
can we do something about healthy food
what do you want to do about it
have some that's so true if you walk
into any hospital cafeteria it's
all wings burgers fries
and it makes no sense because they just
walked out of uh
their meetings with their doctors and
maybe are even out of surgery and we're
telling them you need to eat healthy
food
and then when they walk into the
hospital cafeteria they're bombarded
with fried stuff it makes no sense
so just tell me what you need what your
patients need and i don't care if it's
not covered i don't care if the board
said no let's get into some trouble
let's be doctors again
it's incredibly dramatized unfortunately
a medical director
can't make all those decisions because
as much as we want to be self-righteous
and help everyone and change the system
it takes work it's a step-by-step
process it's not let's have one meeting
and i'll change everything because i'm
superman i read your files you have the
lowest billing rates in the department
what's wrong you don't like surgery
i love surgery then why did you perform
half as many procedures as your
colleagues
because my patients didn't need them
because there's other ways to help
people than by cutting them open
it's a very important statement to make
one of the things i try and encourage my
patients to do when speaking with their
surgeons is to
ask a question do i actually need this
procedure or surgery
because a lot of times uh as the saying
goes if you're a hammer everything's a
nail when you're a surgeon you're meant
to operate
and this isn't to down talk surgeons
because what they do is amazing and
incredibly necessary
but there are times where there are
unnecessary procedures being performed
the first
procedure that comes to mind that's been
statistically
probably over performed in our society
is
cardiac catheterization where they put a
stent in your heart and i'm not talking
about putting a stent in when someone's
actively having a heart attack that's
obviously crucial
but i'm talking about in patients where
there's not a clear benefit
or at least not a clear benefit over
doing just medical therapy
giving them medications changing their
lifestyle that sort of thing
and cardiac catheterizations are a huge
money maker for hospitals
so you see hospitals shift their focus
on performing these procedures
and not focus on prevention on focusing
on
lifestyle factors stop
everyone back away from the patient
masks on
now
does he have tuberculosis
ebola what's going on here we have a
patient in the ed from liberia
presenting all the signs of malaria
or people oh no the first thing we do
is call the mayor's office and the cdc
if we even suspect
ebola virus now the patient is in an
isolation chamber with negative pressure
airflow
that chamber is equipped with every
available medicine should the patient
need
to self-medicate what about us ebola is
an airborne but if you develop symptoms
you will
join him until then you will help him
everyone interacting with the patient is
required to wear personal protective
equipment
at all times no shortcuts ever so this
is interesting because ebola is a
disease caused by a virus
it causes a high fever it actually
causes you to bleed
internally which leads to organ failure
it doesn't really present with any
unique
symptoms abdominal pain headaches
muscular pain fevers low blood pressure
so it's difficult to understand if
someone has ebola or something else so
you have to rule it out the reason why
they suspected in this gentleman is
because when they opened his
documentation they saw where he came
from
and in an area where you have high rates
of ebola like in west africa
you automatically want to assume that
someone has ebola so that it doesn't
contaminate everybody else we don't have
evidence of it spreading through
uh air but we have evidence a lot of
evidence of it spreading through blood
mucous semen basically bodily fluids
and why ebola is dangerous it has a
death rate of basically
one in two and even higher in some
circumstances
you know pens and pencils aren't allowed
outside the classroom the pen's attached
to my journal
okay you'll have to give me the journal
then no you'll get it back in the
morning
it's mine gemma give me the journal
gemma don't do this
gemma
so when you have a patient who has a
psychiatric condition it's important
to not uh be provocative in any
situation because the
situation can escalate a lot quicker
than it would with someone who doesn't
have that condition
in this case perhaps some more
conversation
maybe calling up the doctor because she
has such a great relationship with him
could have fostered better communication
and had her
give up the pen without causing that
much of a scene and her actually hurting
a health care provider
so it was handled poorly but obviously
healthcare worker abuse is not welcome
in any situation
gemma keep it
like what's the point
[Music]
return them to baseline and put them
through the system
that's my job well
if you can't help gemma as a doctor then
just help her as a human being
am i allowed to do that you are now
well i always say be human first one of
the most overlooked parts of being a
doctor
is helping someone human to human a lot
of times because we have
so many patients to take care of we lose
ourselves in the job
and focus on checking boxes and making
sure that
we write our notes carefully so that we
don't get sued but in reality we have to
not forget that we're taking care of
another human being
mrs martin you could stay here
but in this case the treatment is worse
than the disease
and with so little time maybe there's
someplace else you'd rather be
not every patient wants to spend their
last few months or years
in a hospital going in and out of
treatments so it's good that he's doing
that
although this is very very very
simplified
because she should have an evaluation by
an oncologist
who's a professional in that specialty
who can
decide whether or not the patient would
benefit or would not benefit from
treatment
she should maybe even get a second
opinion because as
it's shown before doctors make mistakes
maybe this doctor is mistaken so
i agree with the idea of giving patients
options but i do not agree with
the way he's going about it
oh no it looks like ebola because he's
bleeding out hemoptysis meaning that
he's coughing up blood um i'm not sure
if that's more he's vomiting blood than
coughing up blood
uh but i wouldn't say he's crashing
crashing means
his heart stopping so i would call this
more of a rapid response
so this is very dangerous because
protocol is now going to say that she
has to be kept an observation in
isolation
because who knows if she contracted
ebola and if she did then she
will bring it to other people in the
united states and it could start an
epidemic
lauren i know what you're gonna say that
was
that was stupid i violated protocol
lord a glove
a land that shot they gave you in
liberia they might have thought it was
ebola
but it wasn't it was the last virus
which is just
as deadly except as dr bloom can tell
you
the lassovirus can be treated with
antiviral medication
which we gave you you still probably
should have
had him in isolation just because you
don't want the rest of the staff to get
it and need anti-viral medication
you need to slow down yeah
get that a lot you have cancer
squamous cell carcinoma
how did she know that but you knew that
didn't you
how can i help
i applaud this show for taking a stance
on showing
all of the difficult things that can
happen within medicine how we definitely
need to switch things up and it gets me
excited that people are talking about
this
the show obviously has a lot of dramatic
twists and turns
all in all i'm pleased with the show i
think it was fun to watch
i want to see more episodes i want to
know what you guys thought so jump into
the comment section
tell me what you thought tell me if you
want me to watch more of this show
uh because i think i'm a new amsterdam
fan right now
and i like the acting i think it's well
acted and well written that's for sure
this is the first
video for my little uh video series
that's gonna happen every wednesday at 8
pm eastern standard time
i think i'm going to call it wednesday's
checkup let me know if you like that
title or if you want something different
again jump in the comment section
and as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you